[Music]
patient zero is an action horror film
set against the outbreak of a deadly
virus that threatens to wipe out the
human race we follow a group of
survivors as they desperately try to
find a cure for the disease and watch as
they are slowly torn apart by the new
highly intelligent and ravenous
creatures throughout this video I will
be discussing the plot of patient zero
as well as the film's ending there will
be heavy spoilers so it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you want
to go into the film with fresh eyes
without the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to the
virus rabies has mutated and is even
deadlier than before highly contagious
are now able to turn the infected rabid
within 90 seconds it seems that there is
very little hope for humanity we follow
Morgan played by Matt Smith his wife
Janet and a doctor named Gina Rose as
they struggle to find the cure for the
virus before becomes too late
Morgan seems to be immune to the disease
as he survived an attack which should
have left him rabid instead now he
possesses the ability to communicate
with the infected and holds the key to
curing it with Morgan's communication
ability the survivors interrogate an
infected man and known as patient zero
he is classified as this because he can
speak and is unaffected by the music
that has driven either infected into a
rage he tells Morgan that the infected
or revolt humans a more advanced species
that will wipe the lesser one out and
reveals that he came to the underground
base on purpose and we discover that he
is using a frequency detector so that
the other infected can track him they
begin to storm the base and a battle
ensues between the survivors and the
infected in which several characters die
earlier in the film we learned that dr.
Rose had
I'm pregnant after having sex with
Morgan and this becomes the main thrust
of the ending aware that Morgan holds
the Cure in his blood patient zero
organized the attack as a way to kill
him because he is a threat to the
survival of the infected
this makes Morgan patient zero for the
infected Morgan manages to kill patient
zero however during the fight between
the two he calls out four other infected
that are in the area and they rushed to
his aid as they attempt to escape
Morgan's wife senses that dr. Rose is
pregnant and sacrifices herself in order
to save the baby Morgan and dr. Rose
managed to flee the base and escaped
into the night with Morgan making the
silent promise that he will do whatever
he can to protect the baby and make sure
that the human race survives it's
highlighted throughout that Morgan's
blood is the cure for disease and
therefore the baby will inherit his
immunity some may see this as setting up
for a sequel but I don't believe that
this film needs one whilst we don't get
a definitive answer for their fate I
personally took the ending as
confirmation that the humans will
eventually end the disease due to dr.
Rosa's closeness to the child she will
be able to properly study it as it grows
and manufacture a cure this will either
wipe out the plague or restore the
infected back to sanity so what did you
think of patient zero do you think that
humanity will survive and what was your
favorite part of the film do not say
when the credits rolled because I know
this films getting really bad reviews
anyway comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and subscribe to my channel I
create content like this weekly and
they'll definitely be something on here
that you love if you're a fan of film
make sure you check out my ending
explained video for the predator linked
at the end of this one and thanks again
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]